we're gonna keep working and Chris Sims
has been complaining all day we got to
keep work and got to work we're sitting
here talking we're having fun I'm having
big eyes like charges coach Anthony Lynn
I am having fun I'm just when we're
still here at 4 o'clock doing interviews
I'm gonna be tired so I'm just letting
you know that's all coach yeah I'm good
man
good congratulations on your success so
far as coach of the Chargers new stadium
dish except for this last season but
here's the thing you know Phillip Rivers
said this before the season talking
about 2018 he said we could have been 10
in our 1606 and 10 it was close games is
it just so simple as saying this year
the close games didn't fall for you the
way the close games did the prior year
no they didn't fall for us but I know we
have to figure out a way to win those
close games and that's something that I
thought we did the first two years after
we started on four so that was just a
point that see us take that step back
but right now we're trying to figure it
out to get back on track how much is the
new stadium gonna make a difference
okay I know the guys are excited I mean
we went down and saw the new stadium
last year I'm gonna go back this year
when they finish it and it's I mean it's
like the eighth wonder of the world
I'm just AM is so exciting we can't wait
to get there and play in it is it
frustrating for you the last few years
to go out in the stadium and be like
damn the other teams got more fans there
than us right now you know a little
football yeah and like I tell my team
will play in the parking lot so it
doesn't matter whose it was in the
stands you know we gotta go out and do
our job and executing win football games
that's what we get paid for yeah how
much of is it an organizational focus on
just trying to connect better in LA to
get more of the people who show up to be
Chargers fans as opposed to look at all
the Packers fans look at all the
Steelers fans to just kind of get the
pendulum swinging in your in your
direction yeah we knew it's gonna be
challenging when we moved down the
street but our marketing department
I mean they're doing a heck of a job of
trying to connect with the communities
surrounding us right now and and our
players are there out in the community
doing things and I think the more people
get to see our players and and I have a
really outstanding locker from high
character group and just watch these
young men now how they play the game I
mean it didn't go our way last year but
those young men played hard every single
Sunday and we lost nine one score games
but they were always we were always in
it yeah so the guys played hard we gotta
figure out a way to win more but they
played hard and out this thing people
will respect that once we get to LA now
the direction of the franchise I mean
it's Philip Rivers not there for the
first time and forever you know I mean
what's that gonna be like for you and
kind of how do you vision the future of
the Chargers here going forward well
I'll tell you you know we have got like
Philip Rivers you always feel like you
have a chance on Sundays right and he's
been up for 16 years when I need to
Center and down him not being done
that's gonna be different but I'm
excited for him his new challenge and
for us right so I mean we both decided
to go our own separate ways and now I
wish him and Tiffany all the best in the
world but uh I guess I'm excited with
them yeah so we have safe let's say like
anything's on the table right now the
quarterback position I mean you guys are
kind of still in the prime you know you
got Tyrod Taylor
yeah who's certainly capable of being a
starting quarterback but you mean all
options I guess are available for you
guys right now right now and we're
leaving all the options available yeah
you know we're going through free agency
we're going through the draft but right
having a guy like Tyrod Taylor on the
staff really helps because I've had him
before right and he has grown since the
last time I've had him he is a better
enough for a quarterback right now and
his teammates respect him a lot gives
you some flexibility I would think too
as far as what you're gonna do with the
position absolutely yeah you'd only been
with Phillip Rivers for three years but
he was such an institution as part of
the charges organization how hard was it
to say goodbye to a guy who had been
there since 2004 it was hard I mean it
was really hard but like I said it was a
mutual decision between both and and I
just think it sometimes players they
reach a point in their career where they
need a new challenge you know you saw
that with Brett Farr for Joe Montana and
you know those guys went on in it and
play well you know when they left those
organizations so I expect Phillip Rivers
to do the same thing but at the same
time I'm excited for the direction that
we're heading right now are you excited
to face him at some point that'll be fun
oh he might
she never goes he would talk he won't
curse he talked he talked noise to me
before I became as head coach and I'm
sure you will
[Laughter]
we're at the combine and I'm always
interested because you're you're a lifer
in the NFL and been around so many great
players any like workout and pass like
you just still think of like oh my gosh
I can't believe that guy or just a
player that jumped out to you you know
whether it be a Miles Garrett from a few
years ago just one of those guys that
were just you know freak of nature where
you went oh my gosh I can't believe what
I saw today from that guy I mean you see
that every year I know you do
I know I mean these young man Richard
miles guy yeah goodness yeah I mean I go
all the way back to 92 and I was with
Lawrence Taylor Yeah right okay I mean
my good let me just check with matrix
yeah the things that those guys can do
on a football field
yeah so an athletes are getting bigger
and stronger and faster they are it's
just hard to tell because they're all
they're all the same right now okay you
say that bigger faster stronger and I
know you played some ball I mean what do
you what what's your thoughts on like 17
games extra playoffs extra playoff game
how do you feel about that right no it's
not my decision so how many games we
play and all that I'm I used to be 14
with just the 16 if they make it 17 we
will adjust I know you will I know your
former running back running backs coach
he got a running back in Melvin Gordon
we talked to him at the Super Bowl he
wants to stay with the Chargers do you
believe there's a realistic shot at
keeping him around as free agency
approaches well I do believe that we
love nothing I mean he's outstanding I
mean he held our last shirt that hurt us
a little bit but when he came back his
attitude in the way he fit right back
into the locker room was uh was typical
Melvin and yeah we like to have him back
but you know it's free agency yeah you
never know what's going to happen are
you trying to sign him before free
agency coms you're gonna see let him see
what else is out there before you try to
make a run at him well I mean we have a
strategy for that but I don't want to
anymore all right well this one I know
you will talk about because he's the man
the myth the legend right now like you
get to see him twice a year what's it
like seeing Patrick mahomes cannon gonna
give us our your
Anthony Lin's scouting report on him let
me tell you he's I mean he's the best
I've seen in a long time right I mean he
can do it all
yeah he can make every throw he can
extend every play he sees his vision his
second vision is it's all really good
right and you know playing against him
for the next few years you going out to
be the best you have to beat the best
yeah right and that's the challenge
right well you're gonna get to do it in
that brand-new Stadium which is exciting
who do you hope they'll christen it with
who are you hoping to see the first game
deal with that guy and you know
hopefully you come out on the on the
right side of that one well we
appreciate your time it's been a great
run for the Chargers I know this year
wasn't what you wanted to be what are
you than just winning those close games
is there something Matt is there
something is there anything that you can
point to that you can do to just get
over the hump get past the Chiefs and
get to the post me tell you we can we
can take the ball away and we can stop
turning it over yeah when you're 32nd
and 31st in those two categories it's
gonna be long and that's what we got
correct and we will
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports